hey 42 here if you're one of the people
who spend lockdown
binge watching courtroom dramas you'll
be familiar with the cliches
sudden witness confessions on the stand
overly sassy judges
lawyers objecting lawyers objecting to
other lawyers objecting
and if the defendant is something of a
criminal mastermind
there's a decent chance they'll put
forward an insanity defense
to keep everyone on their toes some of
the most notorious men in recent history
have used the insanity defense ed gean
jeffrey dahmer john wayne gacy
captain edmund blackadder when it works
the insanity defense can appear to be
something of a get out of jail free card
but getting off scot-free on the grounds
of being
a certified nut bag isn't as easy as you
might think
the laws that underpin this kind of
defense are archaic
and complex and they tend to view
insanity
very differently to society as a whole
the history of insanity
in a legal sense at least i'm pretty
sure there have been crazy people for
about as long as there have been people
began with a particularly old law called
the statute the prerogative
regis it was enacted in 1324
to set out the privileges of the crown
which sat on edward ii's head at the
time
and amongst the many laws laid out
within one pertains to the treatment of
both
lunatics and idiots lunatic was someone
whose mental disorder was temporary
or had developed after birth whereas
an idiot was someone whose condition had
existed
from birth this distinction was
important
if you were found to be a lunatic the
king could claim your estate
and provide for your household out of
its profits
but would keep nothing for himself if
you were
a mere idiot however you weren't so
lucky the king could take your land and
pocket any profit
for himself to um
keep it safe up until the 17th century
any laws detailing insanity as a
criminal defense
were fuzzy at best but from what
historians have been able to decipher
the insane would generally go unpunished
for their crimes
for free reasons first punishment for
the most serious crimes
could be so severe it was seen as
cruel to inflict them on the insane for
example
if you were prone to poisoning people
during the reign of henry viii
there's a good chance you'd be boiled
alive
second it was believed that punishing an
insane person
didn't really work as a deterrent as it
did to those who were insane
and finally just like today crimes back
then
required men's reya that's criminal
intent
which an insane person couldn't possibly
possess
from the 17th century onwards however
some clearer definitions of insanity as
a defense
began to appear including in john
bridle's non-compos mentus
the first treatise dedicated solely to
insanity in a legal context
and sir matthew hale's pleas of the
crown
hale's text was particularly influential
and in it he outlined
three specific mental conditions that
could absolve you of a crime
idiocy insanity due to illness
and insanity due to drunkenness
yeah i think most of us have suffered
from a bit of alcohol-related insanity
at one time or another
so it's reassuring to know that's no
longer considered grounds for literally
getting away with murder
according to hail insanity due to
illness could either be
partial or total and if you were found
to be a mere dabbler you'd still be held
accountable for more serious offences
unfortunately for some defendants total
insanity could be an extremely high
threshold to meet
in r vs arnold r represents the crown
the defendant shot and wounded a man
called lord onslow who he believed to
have been responsible
for every loud noise and disturbance
in the whole of england now as far as
i'm concerned
that sounds like the accusation of a man
who's as mad as a box of frogs
but the judge saw things a little
differently telling the jury that
nobody should escape punishment for
murder unless they were totally deprived
of reason
so to get away scot-free he'd have to be
a dedicated
full-time career maniac and since arnold
had
the occasional lucid bout in between
stints wearing his underpants on his
head
the jury found him guilty things went a
little better for a man called hadfield
while serving as a soldier hadfield had
suffered a head injury
leading to him being discharged from the
army later he became convinced he had to
sacrifice his life
for the salvation of the world the head
injuries will do that to you
but as it was considered a sin to commit
suicide hatfield
a devout christian did something
on purpose he hoped would lead to
punishment by death
instead in may 1800 he attended a play
at the drury lane theater in london
king george iii was also in attendance
and as was customary whenever royalty
entered the theater
the orchestra began to play god saved
the king
and everyone stood to attention well
everyone except hadfield he was too busy
drawing a pistol taking aim at his royal
highness his head
and pulling the trigger perhaps hadfield
was a poor shot
or perhaps god took the words of the
audience seriously
because the shots missed its mark now
it's fair to say
high treason was no laughing mata back
in 1800
with the standard punishment being
hanging
disembowelment castration beheading
and quartering of the guilty party
i'm not sure what order that shopping
list of brutality was carried out in
but i don't think it matters it was
going to make you very dead
either way but hadfield believed he was
essentially doing
good by killing the king at least in his
own eyes
and so the jury found him not guilty on
ground of insanity
up until hadfield's case those acquitted
on the ground of insanity
were often released back into the care
of their families
but with an uncharacteristic burst of
momentum
parliament swiftly passed the criminal
lunatics act
to provide for the indefinite detention
of insane defendants
thanks to the new law hadfield was
detained
in bethlehem royal hospital more
commonly known
as bedlam for the rest of his life save
for a short period when he escaped and
attempted to flee to france
yeah one of the most common ways defense
lawyers attempt to demonstrate insanity
in their defendants
is by applying the mcnaughton rules
which come from a famous trial in 1843
in which a man named daniel mcnaughton
was accused of
murder after having attempted to shoot
the prime minister of the united kingdom
robert peel now that kind of business is
bound to get you in trouble with the law
but it turned out mick norton was only
trying to bump off peel
because he was certain the prime
minister was trying to kill
him first in an embarrassing case of
mistaken identity
mcnaughton accidentally took out the
prime minister's secretary
instead but in the subsequent trial he
was acquitted of all crimes
on grounds of insanity the general
public didn't take too kindly to this
outcome
and so the house of lords met in the
aftermath to devise a kind of
framework that could be used to define
insanity
in a legal sense in the future the
outcome of this meeting
was the mcnaughton rules and
despite being well over 150 years old
they're still widely used today and have
influenced the legal defense of insanity
in australia
canada england and wales hong kong
india the republic of ireland new
zealand
norway and most u.s states
to demonstrate innocence on the grounds
of insanity under the mcnaughton rules
the defendant must amongst other things
show he
or she was suffering from a disease of
the mind when committing the crime in
question
which may sound simple enough in
principle
but in practice not so much this
probably won't come as much of a shock
to you
even if you haven't been to medical
school but
a disease of the mind doesn't actually
exist as a specific
medical diagnosis meaning there's plenty
of room for disagreement as to what
exactly is covered by the term
and we aren't talking specific diagnoses
either from the perspective of the
mcnorton rules
the particular condition the defendant
is suffering from
isn't actually important what is
important
is whether that condition could have
caused a defect of reason
to the extent that the defendant either
wouldn't know
what he was doing when he committed a
crime or at least
wouldn't know that what he was doing was
wrong
and this is where insanity in the eyes
of the medical profession
and insanity in the eyes of the law
differ
in the eyes of the law what counts isn't
whether or not a person is
ill but whether whatever it is that's
making him
ill prevented him from understanding the
nature of the act he committed
it's therefore perfectly possible for a
person to be legally insane
whilst being of sound mind medically
and vice versa these days insanity isn't
even a medical diagnosis at all
i should point out that daniel
mcnaughton himself didn't actually
qualify as
insane under the rules that are named
for him
he both knew what he was doing and why
it was wrong
even if his reasons for doing it were a
bit mentally suspect
but his name stuck simply because the
rules were codified in response to his
trial
what's often forgotten when it comes to
the insanity defense is that
as was the case with our man hadfield
who tried to kill the king
even if you're actually successful in
pleading insanity
it isn't like you get to go home and
live a completely normal life
you're still likely to be detained in a
mental health facility of some sort
potentially for longer than the prison
sentence you would have received
if you've been found guilty of the crime
in the first place
but for some individuals that's a risk
worth taking
it's estimated that around 20 of
insanity please
are faked amongst defendants likely to
face the death penalty
which makes sense you might as well give
it a go when you literally have nothing
to lose
whilst i'm sure you would never have a
dream of committing a crime or
avoiding justice let's just imagine
hypothetically
that you do one day find yourself in
need of a sort of
how-to guide on faking insanity
look no further step one
do your homework kenneth bianchi also
known as the hillside strangler
learnt this one the hard way after he
was apprehended for murdering 12 young
women in california
at first bianchi managed to convince
several medical experts during hypnosis
that he had an alter ego called steve
and that it was steve
who'd committed the horrific crimes
because of this
revelation bianchi was diagnosed with
multiple personality disorder
and nearly got off the hook but then the
police decided to bring in
another psychologist named martin horn
owen told bianchi that people who suffer
from multiple personality disorder
usually have at least three
personalities
so bianchi quickly invented another
alias called
billy owns next step was to trick
bianchi
using something called a double
hallucination test
whilst he was under hypnosis he
introduced bianchi to his attorney
who wasn't actually there and bianchi
proceeded to
interact with him whilst still under
hypnosis
when on brought the actual lawyer into
the room
bianchi became flustered and claimed the
imaginary lawyer had disappeared
but owns research had shown that
genuine sufferers of multiple
personality disorder
were basically fine with several
versions of the same person
being in the room with them and so he
became convinced
bianchi was faking eventually causing
bianchi
to change his plea to guilty in furnace
to bianchi he'd put quite a bit of
effort into the charade
when the police searched his house they
found textbooks on psychology
hypnosis police procedure law
and just for good measure the film's
sybil
and the free faces of eve both of which
feature characters
with multiple personality disorder but
faking insanity in front of an expert
is a particularly tricky exam and
despite all his swatting
bianchi was still found out so yeah if
you haven't been revising at the school
of insanity
it probably isn't the best plan for you
to get off scot-free
but if you've got that one down you can
move on to step two
try method acting in 2013
ian brady known for the infamous moore's
murders
appeared as a mental health tribunal
held at assworth psychiatric hospital
he was originally transferred to
assworth after being diagnosed with
paranoid schizophrenia in 1985.
but at the tribunal he fought to be
declared sane
so he could return to prison at the
tribunal the council for assworth asked
brady about his mental health
before he was diagnosed with
schizophrenia
brady replied that he'd been perfectly
sane at the time
and that he'd simply adopted the
techniques of constantine
sanislavsky to fool medical staff
stanislavski was widely recognized in
the early 1900s
as an outstanding method actor meaning
he would get into character
by putting himself in his character's
shoes and acting out different scenarios
which helped him to perform his roles
more convincingly
so according to brady when he was
reacting to hallucinations
talking to himself and banging his fists
against the side of his cell
it was all just part of getting into
character
how much truth was in brady's claim is
unclear
at the time of the tribunal he was
refusing to eat and it was believed he
mostly wanted to go back to prison
so he could commit suicide more easily
whatever the reason the tribunal decided
he was to remain at ashworth which he
did
until he died in 2017. step three
don't boast to your friends about your
cunning plan
in 1996 james lindsay was accused of
strangling a 15 year old girl
he pleaded guilty to the lesser charge
of homicide by pleading insanity
but whilst in prison waiting for trial
in glasgow
lindsay decided to send a letter to a
friend outlining his
cunning plan to get into casters state
hospital
and that he intended to be released
after eight years
in the end the courts learnt of his
cunning plan
and refused to accept his plea of
insanity
step four don't overdo it anne-marie
clark is a clinical psychologist who's
frequently asked to give his medical
opinion on whether someone is attempting
to
fake insanity according to clark one of
the most common giveaways
is reporting dramatic over-the-top
symptoms
which are too extreme to be believed if
you claimed to have had tea with the
queen for example
you might just get away with it but if
you insisted that the queen
was in fact a lizard and leading member
of the illuminati
that would be a bit of a red flag if a
psychiatrist suspected you of being
dishonest
he might suggest a series of symptoms to
you some of these symptoms would make
sense for a certain mental disorder but
others
wouldn't so you might be asked a
question such as
do you ever feel as though strangers
want to hurt you
followed by and do you tend to feel too
warm
during those times essentially the
psychiatrist is leading you to admit to
a set of symptoms
that it's nearly impossible to have
uncovering your lie
in the process it's perhaps because of
tests like these
that insanity defenses are rarely
successful
it's estimated that less than one
percent of all criminal cases
employ the insanity defense and of those
only a quarter succeed as for how many
of those defendants actually
were genuinely insane and not faking
i guess we'll never know after all the
ones who managed to fool the system and
literally get away with murder
are unlikely to ever share their secrets
thanks for watching
you can get your hands on my book stick
a flag in it over
on amazon or on audible links to both in
the description below
thank you